Los Angeles officials are trying to stop
the spread of the flesh-eating drug
zilazine I guess that's taken over the
city the zombie drug a Veterinary
tranquilizer approved in the U.S for
cows and horses is now flooding the
illicit U.S drug Market with dealers
often cutting it with cocaine and heroin
but it's most often used to cut fentanyl
the lethally potent synthetic opioid
that already kills tens of thousands
Americans every year the problem Los
Angeles County Sheriff's officials say
is that the drug is technically a legal
substance when combined with opioids
like fentanyl as it is frequently the
case it enhances the life-threatening
effects of respiratory depression
slowing or stopping a breathing caused
by opioids increasing the risk of
Overdose and death nurses have described
the wounds caused by this drug as
appearing as though something is eating
away at your flesh from the inside out
and this is
yet another reason why we should really
be talking about
much more severe penalties for
the people who are responsible for
putting these kinds of drugs out in the
market